volontiers j'enlève l'oreillette
[Musique]
l'escroquerie foutage de gueule le monde
d'après c'est le monde d'avant empire
[Musique]
le peuple ne doivent surtout pas se
faire le procureur du gouvernement il
doit exiger du gouvernement que le
gouvernement se fasse le serviteur du
peuple c'est à dire des citoyens
assemblée pourquoi parce que
l'étymologie du mot ministre c'est
ministerio c'est le serviteur
[Musique]
alors je ne sais pas très bien ce qu'est
le souverainisme ou en tout cas sûr que
chacun mais dans ce mot qui a été abîmée
depuis des années puisque il sert de
repoussoir comme réactionnaires comme
populiste donc la question n'est pas
celle de souverainisme la question est
celle de la souveraineté et l'idée que
là qu'il faut mettre en place la
souveraineté du peuple qu'il faut
exprimer la souveraineté du peuple et
que ça passe par la souveraineté de la
nation ce n'est ni de droite ni de
gauche c'est tout simplement la
définition de la démocratie il n'ya pas
de démocratie sont souveraineté du
peuple parce que la démocratie c'est le
gouvernement du peuple par le peuple
pour le peuple
[Musique]
il n'ya jamais aucun pronostic politique
qui soit une prévision sur en général
d'ailleurs quand les peuples ne veulent
pas que quelque chose se réalise eh bien
ça ne se réalise pas le suffrage
universel à ceux ci d'un peu particulier
est intéressant qu'il fait en sorte que
les choses se passent différemment et en
général les deux qui sont promis au
second tour dix-huit mois avant ne sont
jamais ceux qui arrivent alors peut-être
que nous aurons droit en effet à une
redite de 2017 mais a priori les
citoyens n'en veulent pas donc si ça
devait arriver ce serait tragique pour
la france parce que ça voudrait dire que
nous n'avons pas résolu ce problème de
blocage total de nos institutions
[Musique]
oui alors je pense qu'il y à différentes
manières de participer au bien commun de
en gros de faire sa part et je pense que
de tout simplement apporter des idées
dans le débat public
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
nécessaire alors que un engagement en
politique ça nécessite différents
facteurs absolument essentiel cela
nécessite d'avoir des troupes ça
nécessite d'avoir de l'argent ça
nécessite des je dirais même on oublie
souvent d'avoir à peu près 500 personnes
prêtes à être placé à la tête des
administrations parce que sinon on est
prisonnier de son administration même
quelqu'un comme emmanuel macron en a
fait l'expérience
donc je pense qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup
de conditions avant qu'un engagement
politique soit réellement efficace
[Musique]